thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you I love that interview the
reporters passersby yes yeah I think
people are people are interested in this
topic sleep is very big thing for us all
exactly including the minister including
the minister absolutely I I think I
think you usually unless I'm mistaken
here your interest interest in this
topic sleep started with you waking up
in the pool of love well with me coming
to a collapsed from sleep deprivation
exhaustion and hit my head on my desk
and I came to you know when I regained
consciousness in a pool of blood because
I broke my cheekbone and so that's what
started me really studying all the
science about the importance of sleep
because I like millions of people
thought that if we're going to achieve
and get a lot of things done sleep or
something we could sacrifice and now all
the modern science around sleep proves
conclusively that the majority of people
unless you have a genetic mutation which
means you can do fine on four or five
hours the vast majority of people need
seven to nine hours to be able no no yes
and somewhere in between you know you
may do fantastic on seven I need a to
operate on all cylinders
or you may need nine but somewhere in
that spectrum in order to be fully
effective and fully present in your life
you've done a lot of research on this
and and what happens if we lack sleep
over a longer period well there's
various amazing science around that now
first of all for me the most kind of
dramatic new study is one and that shows
that contrary to what we used to believe
for centuries
which is that when we go to sleep our
brain is inactive in a little bit like
putting the car in the garage and
turning the ignition off all the new
research shows that in fact sleep is a
time of frenetic activity for the brain
but y1 or awake the brain is alert when
we are asleep the brain is cleaning up
all the toxins that have accumulated
during the day the only time that can be
cleaned up is during sleep so if you
think of it if we don't clean up it's
like we're professionally eating off
dirty plates and if we don't clean up
our memory deteriorates in fact they
have now found a link between sleep
deprivation Alzheimer's a cognitive
performance is reduced our immune system
is lowered so we can get calls who can
get sick more easily so every aspect of
both our physical and our mental health
is affected so how do you think yeah I
sleep like a baby you know you sleep
three hours wake up and cry sleep too
you know I I also sometimes have
sleeping problems
I'm better at waking up because I like
to go into cold water swim in cold water
and so on but there so you wake up and
immediately go to swim I know now I even
like to to take a shower a very cold
shower in the morning yeah I have but
what about do you have a transition to
sleep at night I never had the
opportunity to ask a foreign minister
about that full advantage so do you have
a transition to sleep like you're
incredibly busy a lot of demands on your
time
what happens at what some point you
decide I'm going to turn off the lights
and what do you do with your phone I I
think we get too little sleep you're
absolutely right I remember from being a
minister for Health and Social Affairs
that I read some of these reports about
if you have sleep deprivation and
actually if you sleep less than six
hours regularly and most people need
those seven to nine hours then the risk
of getting a very serious illness or
disease increases by 50% yes so it is
really very very dangerous also for all
they did not make you change your habits
well I I need sleep and I try to use
sometimes meditation as a method to just
get to see ya but I read a lot what
about that
oh yes reading is great but I think III
really not of not work things no but if
you're anything about the state of the
world
ya know not going to you you will never
sleep again you keep it dark or how do
you very dark as dark as possible and
called since you like the call that's
not a problem the other thing one of the
the ladies answered the question what
does she wear to bed if she said she was
sweatpants and a t-shirt so if you were
the same things that you go to the G
mean it's not good for your brain
because your brain gets confusing
messages like we're wearing our gym
clothes that we've gone to the gym or
we're going to sleep so I love the idea
of rekindling their romance with sleep
and wearing kind of beautiful lingerie
even if you are sleeping alone just
something that clearly denotes sleep
yeah well like I couldn't
different well even if you have a
dedicated t-shirt that you don't wear to
the gym it's your sleep t-shirt